[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
oh documents documents documents
documents here documents there documents
everywhere
all documents are not created equal I
guess maybe maybe not the media doesn't
seem to think so
foreign yesterday we watched as Merrick
Garland the Attorney General of the
United States announced a special
counsel into the nothing Burger of the
documents that were found
in places that Joe Biden
had them I guess
listen
do you out there freaking out especially
the media I'm talking to you you stupid
[ __ ]
freaking out about the special counsel
and what does it mean what is it does it
mean what does it mean politically and
blah blah blah blah yeah this is not bad
politically for the Democrats at all
listen this steals away the Republicans
and Trump's narrative
about his problem that he has about
stealing our documents from our
government to cover up his attempt to
coup our election
it's not complicated it really isn't
yeah they want to be like oh do these
apples and these oranges look the same
no
and that's why it's not politically bad
for Biden that's the question from the
media this morning how is this how is
this special counsel bad for Joe Biden
it's not
it is not going to turn out bad
politically or criminally listen the
Trump organization
the business that Donald Trump and his
family have run for decades
now I'm going to tell you the actual
amount that they were fined this morning
that the judge ordered them the pay for
their criminal tax fraud
you're not gonna like it because it's
not near enough
oh it's not near enough
1.6 million dollars get the [ __ ] out of
here
one point that's not near
enough for the crimes that they've
committed
but that's what the judge ordered you
know
Justice isn't always served Alan
weiselberg is going to do five months at
Rikers which again still isn't enough
yeah five years ten years 15 years I
don't know we get up in those numbers
might be enough at Rikers of course one
day at Rikers is like 10 years there I I
hear
I would not want to be locked up at
Rikers for five minutes nope
but Trump and his family
were just fine criminally not civilly
right there's a different case that is
the civil case
that will likely take down the Trump
organization in New York that's the one
where it's in receivership they actually
have to have a court-ordered monitor to
make sure that Donald Trump isn't
walking away with all the [ __ ] money
that they owe the state of New York
in the years that they defrauded New
York out of taxes
with this scheme of property values and
other things mainly the property value
scheme
but they're criminals they're [ __ ]
criminals you want to know the
difference between the documents that
they found next to a Corvette and the
documents that
the [ __ ] Cheeto dust q and honor was
harboring down at Mar-A-Lago to cover up
his attempted coup you want to know the
difference one person is a [ __ ]
criminal the other one isn't
on any average day
of granting
top secret clearance to any individual
the federal government would not
Grant Donald Trump top secret
classification
to where he can look at those documents
on any average day Joe Biden would be
able to get that clearance
the only reason why Donald Trump even
had his grubby little [ __ ] hands on
our documents was because a bunch of
[ __ ] around this country thought
that The Apprentice was real
The Apprentice the TV show was all
[ __ ] just like the reality TV
dumpster fire that we have now the
Republican Party
leaking into the House of
Representatives our house
is a reality TV show dumpster fire
it's not real it's all fraud all of it
so you want to know the difference Media
or anyone else out there Republican
Democrat liberal people tweeting
you stupid [ __ ] the difference is one
person has Criminal Intent and is a
criminal
the other person is not
he stole the documents to cover up his
crimes
Donald Trump
you're not gonna find that in this Biden
document case there it's just not going
to exist
good luck that's why I cheer the special
counsel [ __ ] them you goddamn right
there should be three uh just a point a
special Counsel on everything for Joe
Biden for that matter [ __ ] yeah let's do
it gas prices inflation gas stoves for
crying out loud lots of point of special
counsel let's really waste the
government's time if we're gonna do it
and the Republicans think this is good
for them no it is not and Democrats
think this is good for Republicans no it
is not
the media think this is bad for Biden no
it is not
narrative and messaging is 99 of
politics people and you are the
messaging and message messaging and the
narrative you are
it's you
uh to even dream
that people would think
that there is some kind
of through line between these two
documents
it's absolutely flabbergasting to me
it's hilarious
that the media I mean at douchey Ducey
excuse me
with Fox News ask the the famous
question yesterday
you had these documents next to your
Corvette what were you thinking what the
[ __ ] so what if it was a Honda Civic
would that make it better
what if it was one of elon's [ __ ]
Teslas that will go up in Flames is that
better
douchey
the [ __ ] and again yesterday I told you
that the Corvette is going to be a key
part of this story
and you might think it's a bad part it
is not it's a good part that's that's
the best part frankly in the whole
[ __ ] story
I mean when you go in his garage to look
at a box of documents are you gonna
stare at the documents are you going to
look at that [ __ ] 1967 Corvette
that's the thing you're going to be
interested in [ __ ] those documents
it's one of the most interesting things
about Joe Biden versus Donald Trump in
the first place is Joe Biden actually
knows how to drive a car
funny
how that Macho machismo thing works
which by the way we're gonna get into
today we missed a couple stories here
over the last few days and the right
wing is freaking out again about
Eminem's and Eminem's not having this
the the genitalia tell you that they
would like to put in their mouth
you know because it melts in your mouth
not in your hand so they're really they
really want to make sure it has the
right I don't know what the [ __ ] this
imminent story is about but we're gonna
smoke that out today probably in bone
end of the week
and then this gas stove thing
oh [ __ ]
I can't I can't even with these
[ __ ]
cancel culture you can't get take it out
of my cold dead hands well take my take
my female M M's out of my cold dead
hands you [ __ ] I don't
understand this stuff these people these
people are not serious
they're not serious
you can't even use satire this [ __ ]
anymore
they're so [ __ ] ridiculous
gas stoves and M M's I'm not [ __ ]
you that's what we're gonna talk about
today
it ain't because I want to [ __ ] talk
about it
it's because they're I mean they're just
scraping the bottom of the barrel folks
trying to find anything anything they
can find yeah here's another story that
we might talk about today the Missouri
legislator
the Missouri legislator
is spending time
in their regular order of business to
figure out what women should and should
not wear what the [ __ ] happened to free
speech and individualism huh
where where are those Republicans
where's the freedom caucus at huh where
are they at oh that's right they're not
for [ __ ] freedoms they're not for
[ __ ] choice they want to choose and
tell you what to do
it's absolutely ridiculous
that that
not too far from here
they're [ __ ] spending
government time and government resources
in the state of Missouri to try to
figure out how much how much of a
woman's arm is allowed in an official
chamber of the legislator Jesus [ __ ]
Christ are you [ __ ] me
what jackets they can wear I don't even
know what a cardigan is I don't I don't
kill me Sue me I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't know what it is I don't know
fashion so why in the [ __ ] would I tell
someone else what the [ __ ] they can and
can't wear who gives a rat ass let me
tell you something if you told if you
[ __ ] forced
men to not wear something
oh my God they would lose their [ __ ]
minds they would lose their [ __ ] mind
can you imagine if you told half these
[ __ ] old ass wrinkly ass ball sack
men that they couldn't wear a certain
type of diaper on the floor yeah they
would lose their [ __ ] minds they like
their brand of diaper God damn it
can you imagine they couldn't [ __ ] in
the diaper they want to [ __ ] in
it's [ __ ] ridiculous
they'd lose their minds nope nope they
gotta spend time telling women what the
[ __ ] they can and can't wear
[ __ ] wearing lifts in their
shoes wearing [ __ ] garter belts to
suck in their waist so they look skinny
die in their [ __ ] hair putting spray
Tanner all over their goddamn face
and they're gonna tell women what they
can and can't wear
the [ __ ] out of here
listen this is all good politics though
this is all good politics
you think for a minute
that us as the as the pro-democracy
Coalition the people who are actually
for equality and equity and freedom
that that this story out of Missouri
that the story about the gas stoves the
story about the M Ms and them freaking
out about it over [ __ ] nothing
nothing they're freaking out over
nothing
because they're trying to get the
[ __ ] the megalodites all hopped up on
Q Anon
and masculinity I whatever the [ __ ] that
means as if gastos M M's and women
wearing what they want to wear has
anything to do with your masculinity
look guys it's not about you and not
everything's about your [ __ ]
masculinity let me tell you something
about being a man
especially a heterosexual man guys out
there what the [ __ ] does it matter what
a woman wears
how the [ __ ] could you give two shits
how why
you want you want her to tell you what
to wear what you can and can't wear no
no you don't
and if you got a problem if it makes you
get all kinds of weird feelings inside
of you or based on what a woman's
wearing that's a you problem buddy
that is a [ __ ] you problem not a her
problem
that's right it's a [ __ ] you problem
and you need to check your problem not
her it ain't her [ __ ] problem
where she shops and what she wears
and if you can't if you can't control
yourself and your feelings
your feel feels
especially down there then you need to
check yourself
maybe check yourself in somewhere
with a pair of handcuffs or something
you rapey [ __ ]
anyways that's beyond the point I guess
uh it is the point
men telling women what they can and
can't wear oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
especially acting like it's some kind of
comes from a an area of masculinity
listen
masculine men are confident so confident
they don't give a [ __ ] what anyone else
is wearing
you got it dudes you alpha males
Nick Adams
I don't know did you see this video
we're gonna play this video later on in
bonehead
I believe that's where we're gonna play
it of Nick Adams you've seen this guy
he's a self-proclaimed Apple Man on
Twitter
he's he's in the full freak out mode uh
because Tucker Carlson did it did a
thing about M M's and apparently they're
late on this story this I mean this
packaging is months old and they're just
trying to find something to [ __ ]
[ __ ] about wieners and non-weeners they
can't they haven't been focused on
genitalia enough so they got to focus on
Eminem's genitalia apparently I don't
know who gives a [ __ ] [ __ ] how Eminem
is marketing their product
what the [ __ ]
Eminem's don't have genitalia just like
the Mr Potato Head didn't have genitalia
why why are you people freaking out
about what sex the m m is just by the
[ __ ] open the package pour them
in a bowl if you have to they look the
same you stupid [ __ ] it's candy
what are you what are you doing what are
you doing and frankly Eminem Mars the
the company that owns Eminem is
brilliant in all this
it took several months for these [ __ ]
idiots to catch on
no one would have noticed this no one
would you have noticed what package the
M Ms were in
no do you do you do you really focus
you're like oh man
look how they changed the packaging well
son of a [ __ ] I mean this is an attempt
by Mars to appropriate women's rights
and women's activism
to try to stoke the right wing and
paying attention to their product
I mean Mars isn't Mars is an innocent
here I mean God damn I if I was in a
room
and I was paid big money by a
corporation to Market a product you
think I wouldn't use these [ __ ] alpha
males on the internet
and Tucker Carlson to make sure everyone
knew the packaging
was four women and they did a brilliant
job a brilliant job
to look like they're pro- women's rights
which they may be I'm not saying they're
not I don't know anything about Mars or
the people over there in the rooms that
are making this packaging and doing the
marketing I'm just saying seems pretty
[ __ ] brilliant of them doesn't it
doesn't make you want to go out and buy
a box
of M M's just because these [ __ ]
moglodytes are [ __ ] butt hurt about
it yes it does
I don't know maybe it's Brilliance maybe
it's not maybe it's just me
Eminem's give me a [ __ ] break
gas stoves oh we're gonna go over this
stupid story too
apparently apparently now they want an
amendment to the Constitution for gas
stoves
their individual right
the bare gas stoves
you know in case that tyrannical
government ever comes along
and forces you to cook with electric or
whatever I don't know
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is wrong with
these asshats
most people are cooking in an air fryer
right now anyways you stupid [ __ ] don't
you know about trends no one gives a
[ __ ] about your gas stove they're all
cooking in air fryers right now doubt me
I know you [ __ ] are cooking in an air
fryer you probably got a nice one for
Christmas didn't you
yeah you'd be cooking [ __ ] in an air
fryer yeah cooking on a [ __ ] stove
anymore
everybody knows that
go with the air fryer God damn it
oh these [ __ ] idiots man I just I I
listen
the thing is is all this is good
this is not bad
politically
for us
listen six months from now eight months
from now maybe a year from now they're
gonna trudge out a new Eminem story
you think Mars hasn't caught on that
these [ __ ] boneheads
will just absolutely buy the bait
and then everyone starts talking about
them
everyone's gonna be talking about M M's
it took us several months for the m m
story to catch on the outrage the
outrage but it's here
but the most important thing
that I want you to remember every single
day that you hear my voice here which is
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube which you should subscribe
right now right now if you're listening
I don't care if you're on YouTube or not
come over to YouTube we're we're trying
to get to twenty thousand the mods will
tell you in the chat
I'm trying to get the twenty thousand
it's been two years of Tony tomorrow
January 14th will Mark the second or the
very my very first episode the second
year here though
of the Tony Michaels podcast we went
live
as the the house was voting for the
first and or the excuse me the second
impeachment charges Jesus Christ can't
keep track with this [ __ ] Criminal
the second impeachment charges for
January 6.
that was on January 14th
2021. here we are two years later
and the audience has grown and grown
you're the best audience of the world
you're the best audience in the world
and the reason why you love to come here
isn't because of my cute face my [ __ ] em
hats my great voice the reason why you
come here
is to get the messaging and to get the
narrative down
and that's my goal over the next two
years two more years of Tony that is my
goal
and and it is I I cannot do it without
you I can't do it without you I can yell
and scream all day long if there's only
a few people listening well then those
few people
but we have we have to grow this
narrative we have to grow this messaging
and I'm asking you to help me what you
can do it's really easy
is go to the YouTube channel the Tony
Michaels podcast subscribe and listen
not just you share this with three
people just like we did last year in the
midterms of voting
if you got three people out there and
they got three people out there
committed committed to go voting and we
could do this together and right now we
can do this over the next two years we
can use these political narratives we
can use this messaging against them yes
the documents that the Attorney General
appointing a special counsel for the
Biden documents is a good narrative
trust me we will steal away their
narrative on the documents over the next
two years especially here on the Tony
Michaels podcast this is not good for
Trump this is very very bad for Trump
and House Republicans that Merrick
Garland appointed a special counsel
immediately and I know a lot of people
are like oh my God it took mayor Garland
this long to appoint a special counsel
for Donald Trump a two sentence for Joe
bite shut the [ __ ] up
shut the [ __ ] up you're just playing
into their narrative you dumb
[ __ ] you're playing it do their
messaging and their narrative is what
you're doing
and it may feel good to tweet that [ __ ]
but you're hurting democracy you you
were hurting democracy when you do that
because the messaging matters and that's
why you come here every single weekday
because I'm the first one out the gate
first [ __ ] one I've told you
here that I don't want Santos to resign
[ __ ] that [ __ ] keep him in All two years
I will make them pay for him every step
of the way all of them every [ __ ]
step I will make them pay for it in
messaging and narrative
I'll give it to you and you carry it out
there and you spread it around
how do you think politics Works how do
you think you win elections
this is how you do it not not [ __ ]
not [ __ ] money I mean yeah you need
money
but it ain't those [ __ ] it it
definitely trust me it definitely is not
the strategist on the hill they don't
know a [ __ ] thing about strategy or
messaging you have no idea right now
Democrat strategist political
strategists or Washington they're
freaking out oh my God what are we gonna
do about this Biden thing how are we
gonna how are we gonna not talk about
the Biden document shut the [ __ ] up
talk about it every goddamn day of the
week
pointed out mock them over it
that's how you do it
and you want a master class in it just
go watch yesterday's first 30 minutes
I'm telling you
I didn't even know mayor Garland was
going to appoint a special counsel
yesterday in the first 30 minutes go
listen to that tell me tell me that any
of that messaging has to change based on
the special counsel not a [ __ ] word
of it not a goddamn word of it and the
reason why
is because you don't have to get
complicated in your messaging you don't
have to get complicated in your
narratives
but it's up to you to carry that
narrative it's up to you to carry that
messaging yes you matter in your
democracy and it's not just about your
[ __ ] ballot
it's about what you're saying how you're
viewing it what you know
and how you use it
it's important
you think politics is a bunch of talking
that's all it is
that's why politicians piss people off
because that's all they do is blow hot
air
most of them don't know how to do it
I don't
especially on the pro-democracy side
they get too mired up in policy making
and
and bullet points and bills
and line items that they're going to
provide to their constituents
and they forget that there's a national
narrative that has to happen this
country has a mood about it and it's
politics
one of the most important tenements and
foundations of our democracy
it's not about who's elected it's about
how
that's the key
and it's up to you
the audience so make sure you subscribe
here on YouTube
and again if you're on another platform
come on over come on over just go to
YouTube and type in the Tony Michaels
podcast it'll bring you right there I'm
telling you right there whip
we are we are googleable you can even
Google us just Google the Tony Michaels
podcast it'll take you right there right
here
we've got a big enough audience large
enough crowd
and we have fun every single weekday for
two full hours we don't [ __ ] around
I don't give you dead air space Have you
ever sat here and listened for like 40
seconds
waiting for me to say something no
have you ever heard a really stupid
really really stupid [ __ ] angle
mired in facts and statistics like
Pac-Man have you ever heard me have
defeatism like The Young Turks no
absolutely not you won't get it from me
not here so that's what you're looking
for bounce the hell out of here you're
in the wrong spot
if you're looking something for somebody
who's willing to fight for democracy
and build a coalition to fight for
democracy
with raw and real truth you're in the
right spot you're in the right spot and
I thank you for two full years holy [ __ ]
it's been two years it's incredible and
you're incredible
you're the best audience in the world
everyone give love to the moderators as
well because not only do we have the
best
audience we have the best moderators in
the entire world everyone don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
this
we'll be right back
mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babble mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
foreign
this is the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around through the
break as you always do
[Music]
what should we go to First
you do the Biden documents thing should
I pound that drum a little more I think
that is what we are gonna do
I want to show you something here this
is important this was a Byron Byron
Donald's you remember this guy they
thought it'd be really cute to nominate
him as a Speaker of the House
because he switched his vote for
McCarthy
and then they started nominating him
you know
Democrats nominate the very first black
man Hakeem Jeffries as Speaker of the
House Republicans just can't have any of
that so they're gonna have their own
token black guy but this guy is dumber
than you think
he's not just the one that is the one
they nominated
he's he's dumb as dog [ __ ] I'm gonna
show you why he's a lying piece of [ __ ]
too you know everyone keeps acting like
George Santos is some kind of outlier
I keep telling people this George Santos
is not an outlier here
why do you want him to resign if if you
had to actually ask George Santos to
resign for the lies he's told yeah you
gotta ask them all to resign every
[ __ ] one of them like I said Jordan's
the only thing that makes George Santos
any different than any other Republican
is normally Republicans pick three maybe
four lies sometimes up to 10 lies they
continue to tell about themselves or
other [ __ ]
even though it's a blatant lie everyone
knows it's lie it's easily ejected it's
a [ __ ] lie it's a goddamn lie
but they stick with three or four up to
ten depending on the despicableness of
that in particular Republican you know
Jim Jordan tells a lot of [ __ ] lies
he might be able to you know you might
see him in the 12 to 15 category at any
moment any given moment in his career
he's really violent despicable Matt get
same way George Santos though he's like
oh I like all the lies all of them like
every [ __ ] one of them apparently the
guy invented uh some kind of oil
extraction I don't know if you heard
this Jesus Christ
this guy's brilliant
he he literally looks at any lie that
Republicans said tell no matter what
part of the LIE it is or what subject
it's on he's like I like that one I'm
gonna lie about that
yeah why you want him to resign
why because he's a Republican
okay well I mean that's good enough for
me but
um this is Byron Donalds this morning on
Fox Business
of course uh spewing a bunch of [ __ ]
lies this is only 23 seconds and this
guy this guy lies a [ __ ] lot
in this goddamn clip
um but let's listen here to Mr Donald's
and so people will say oh they're not
already the internet trying to complain
come compare this to Donald Trump it's
one very key delineation Donald Trump
was a president of the United States who
has the ability the singular ability as
head of the Executive Branch to
declassify information and he has
actually been working with the National
Archives about that for a year and a
half okay this is just this is just
patently false all around
yeah yeah the president of the United
States the current one which is Joe
Biden you stupid [ __ ]
has the ability to declassify anything
he wants
but
there is a process you don't just
wink
and by the power of a magic Genie
against Declassified that's what you
guys claim he did you [ __ ] idiot and
then he was not cooperating with Nara
that's the point that's why Nara had to
go to the [ __ ] Department of Justice
and the FBI to get him to go get the
[ __ ] that Donald Trump was keeping from
them you dumb [ __ ] here's the
thing
the only reason why we know that main
differences between these cases do you
want to know the reason why we know the
main difference between these cases is
because Donald Trump
he is the main reason why we know
anything
about these cases
in any regular order any regular time
when someone an official in the
government
misplaces or mishandles a classified
document that investigation is not
public they don't announce it to the
world that oh my God
this secretary or whatever had a [ __ ]
classified document and it was
accidentally mishandled
yeah don't do that that's not a thing
they do
there's a lot of there's a lot of
classified information that runs around
Washington uh Congress people are pissed
off today
yeah they're yelling screaming on the
media which is really stupid
as if as if Congress people have any
idea about classified information in the
executive branch it works completely
different
members of Congress have to go to a
special place a special skiff to view it
the executive branch has a lot of places
that you view it
a lot some of them even have Skiffs set
up in their own personal private offices
where this information can be read or
close to their office
because they have to handle so much
classified information on a regular
basis
this is not foreign
to a lot of government officials and
government bureaucrats this classified
information is not
there's a lot of [ __ ] classified
information there's a lot of different
markings
we classify a lot of stupid information
in this country probably too much and
frankly maybe that's a discussion that
could actually come good of this
but on any average normal day
if Donald Trump would have mistakenly
packed up some documents that weren't
his that he shouldn't have had
possession of and took on the Mar-A-Lago
and Nara said hey man I think you got
some of these documents can we come
check it out that person would have said
yeah sure come on down and the FBI that
Nara would have sent the FBI to make
sure to secure those documents if they
were there
and he would have handed him over no
question yeah sure they're not supposed
to be here because of how classified
information is supposed to be handled no
one would have known about it no one
because he [ __ ] said something and he
kept telling lies about it everyone
knows
and he kept telling lies in court so the
Department of Justice had to battle him
in court remember you remember the whole
special Master thing well the reason why
it escalated to that point because it
became a criminal matter
there was a warrant that the FBI went to
get his documents that a judge a federal
bench judge
ordered
based on three statutes that probably
more than likely had been broken
criminally with these documents
that is not the case
that's not the case Biden you stupid
[ __ ] not even close not even close it's
not even the same story to be quite
Frank with you not even close to the
same story The only reason why you
conflate it is because Donald Trump
stole top secret documents to cover up
his coup
and Joe Biden happened to probably
accidentally mishandle
someone packed those [ __ ] documents
in boxes by mistake
because in the Penn Biden Center which
is a that is where Joe Biden after he
left the vice presidency
in 2016
he resided that office in Washington at
the Penn Biden Center
he had an office there there was boxes
from his vice presidency there probably
because he was writing his book
this is not complicated and it just so
happened that Penn State wanted
at the Penn Biden Center to use that
office space so what what did the Biden
team do did they send a bunch of lackeys
over
to pack these boxes and go to storage
units no they hired attorneys to go
through this stuff and that's when they
found it it was turned over immediately
just like protocol says there was
investigation open just like protocol
says the media is a is a bunch of
[ __ ] dummies
in this case
and so is Byron Donald's here
but he's playing into our hand here when
he's saying this stupid [ __ ] listen if
if the case is Byron Donald's that
Donald Trump is cooperating with Nara
which he's not and he didn't that's the
point
then so is Joe Biden
and if it's a waste of government
resources
and if it is the government targeting
someone to investigate them over a
document's issue where they're
cooperating with Nara then why aren't
you yelling and screaming
that the government is being weaponized
in the Congress by your caucus
to to Target the president in the United
States who by the way is immune from all
crimes according to Trump and his allies
so even if Joe Biden committed grants
well he's immune from him by God and he
can pardon himself that's what we hear
right
he can pardon himself I don't know I'm
just saying
now there's one person that's not going
to give two shits two [ __ ] about Byron
Donald's going on Fox Business and lying
his ass off
Jack Smith Jack Smith in his criminal
investigation on Trump not about the
documents about January 6 because folks
the Trump documents case is not the doc
it's not a document's case that I mean
he may get criminal charges because he
intentionally mishandled these documents
in an attempt to to obstruct an
investigation on his coup attempt and
then he obstructed them getting the
documents back so he may [ __ ] receive
charges on that but Jack Smith doesn't
give a single [ __ ]
what lies Byron Donald's or any other
dumb son of a [ __ ] says remember that
and they don't he does not give a [ __ ]
how the media spends this he's not going
to give a [ __ ]
he won't
he won't give two shits about what the
other special counsel is doing
the other Pastor Council that is looking
into Biden documents to make sure that
it is what it appears to be because
that's the difference
the one special counsel is appointed for
January 6th
and the attempt to steal documents to
cover up the coup attempt on January 6th
and possible collusion in the 2016
election it seems
and maybe even maybe even stealing
documents for blackmail to make him
president again so he can protect
himself from the crimes that he
committed for the 2016 collusion
and the coup attempt on January 6th
you think Jack Smith gives two [ __ ]
if the if the special counsel who's
supposed whose job it is that Merrick
Garland upon yesterday whose job it is
to make sure
to make sure because the U.S attorney in
Illinois couldn't finish the
investigation he's leaving
so they had to appoint a special counsel
it only makes sense
mayor Garland said that yesterday in his
announcement that the attorney that he
appointed back in November
to make sure
to do all the interviews to make sure
all the people who had custody of these
documents
every Rock was overturned to make sure
there was no intentional mishandling of
these documents they weren't finished
yet
the Biden's attorneys weren't finished
looking for these to see if there were
any more documents anyplace else
to think that a special counsel to make
sure that what is what it what seems to
be
a mishandling an intent an unintentional
mishandling of documents
Is What It Seems
is is the exact same as a special
counsel
who is assigned
to make sure
that the documents that were stolen from
our government government
to cover up a coup attempt
which is Criminal is what it seems
Criminal
criminal and again I have to tell you
the biggest difference
between these two special counsels
is the targets of these councils
Joe Biden
has no Criminal Intent
he's never been charged with a crime
today
in the state of New York
the other guy that's being investigated
by Jack Smith the other special counsel
is ordered by a judge to play 1.6
million which is not near enough
not near enough but it's a maximum in
this case 1.6 million dollars
and criminal restitution for criminal
tax fraud that him and his family and
his business
defrauded the state of New York
criminal that's short of the difference
you see do you see that you see it do
you see the difference
you see do you see media do you see the
difference Trump's a criminal Biden
isn't
get your head out of your ass on this
okay
maybe enough on that one yeah oh and and
Byron Donald's um he can [ __ ] off too
yeah you [ __ ] all the way off [ __ ] him
in a lion sack of [ __ ] again I don't
know why
why this is um
some sort of
story about Santos where he needs to
resign again I
he really should not resign
I think he should hold fast hold fast in
this I want to bring up another dumb
[ __ ] here
um all you out there in the state of
Texas I'm sorry I'm really sorry
that you are lacking a serious senator
in your state you really are lacking
though
uh Ted Cruz tweeted this out big story
coming tomorrow Hillary's server is also
in Joe's Garage
again
uh you have a United States Senator he
knows exactly how classified information
Works he knows exactly the differences
between the two cases
he knows exactly but again this is why I
say the special counsel this right here
this [ __ ] this this [ __ ] right here
is exactly why I say the special counsel
is good for our narrative this is the
best they can do folks
this is the best they can do
the best they got
in their Narrative of this document
story
they've lost the plot here it's slipped
away from them
because they're going to accuse
and hand ring
over this Joe Biden documents case
and all in the same breath
gonna make sure to solidify the nation
when Jack Smith comes and brings the
charges and the American people know
what the [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] did with with
his documents what a bunch of idiots
um here's another [ __ ] bonehead
about this document [ __ ] here's another
one that's going to lose narrative
they're going to lose it they're well
they've already lost it
but I said she runs face first into it
and you remember this slug
Kimberly Guilfoyle this is Donald
Trump's uh girlfriend Beyonce I I don't
know I don't know if they're married yet
or not to absolve themselves from
uh spouses happening to testify against
each other in federal court I'm not sure
exactly they've done that yet they might
be married I don't know uh but this is
Kimberly Guilfoyle I'm talking about the
[ __ ] difference in the document [ __ ]
and she runs face first into it listen
to this and it's only 17 seconds why
aren't they going full force and measure
against him instead they rated president
Trump's Mar-A-Lago home going through
melania's closet and drawers in a
Despicable manner treating it like they
were um you know doing a raid on you
know Isis it's just absolutely insane
but the American people see through this
like they were doing a raid on Isis
Kimberly I couldn't agree with you more
that you are like Isis yes that is right
you are a bunch of [ __ ] domestic
terrorists I would bring up the banner
that they put and seat back uh in Texas
but we've all seen it we all know they
like this domestic terrorism label yeah
you're you're the American Taliban
you're American Isis yeah we we get it
wisest white white ices yeah whatever
you want to call it I don't know
she always runs face first into it
though they always do they always do why
wouldn't they oh my God okay um
let's see
there's one oh
oh
this is this is a great two minutes of
pathetic Republican [ __ ] uh everyone
was excited when Paul Ryan said this
[ __ ] on Jake tapper's show yesterday
about Donald Trump let me tell you
something don't
here's the stupid thing
liberals sometimes do it's a good
example is Liz Cheney and Adam right I
told you the whole time be very careful
about cheering those [ __ ] on do
not cheer them on do not act like
they're Heroes they are not Heroes they
did the bar the bare minimum to reach
the bar of decency in our democracy
they they believed the truth
holy [ __ ] can you imagine that they
believed the truth and the truth was is
that the former president Donald Trump
tried to overthrow our election he
attempted a coup
and they believed it
great for you now
Paul Ryan here says a couple sentences
that makes liberals feel good listen you
don't get any bigger scumbag than this
[ __ ] and he's trying to make a
comeback here with his book oh yeah
don't worry Paul Ryan's gonna be back oh
yeah he is he wants to be back in
politics he thinks he's the man to carry
the message he's always thought that
that's why he was reluctant to be
speaker because he knew it was his last
day in politics when he accepted the
speakership because a republican caucus
is full of a bunch of [ __ ]
troglodytes but here is Paul Ryan on CNN
let's listen
I know that when you were speaker and
Donald Trump was President you guys
would talk about this and he did not
understand why you would ever want to do
it because it's bad power that's right
that's right he just didn't think it was
ever popular and he has and I'm not
blaming this all on him but he has
certainly empowered the kind of populism
you're talking about Smash Mouth clicks
cable hits on Fox Etc where you're a
board member by the way um he has
popularized that he has empowered that
we saw it last week so how can this be
achieved even within the Republican
party before you even get to the
Democrats couple things
okay
now again this is all part political
posturing by uh Paul Ryan and he knows
that Donald Trump is going to attack him
here with what he's going to say next
um and he's intending that that's his
intention he wants to divide up the
Republican Party he knows the only way
to smoke out Maga and get him out of the
party is to piss them off
let's continue with what he's gonna say
this is what everyone was excited about
which what Paul Ryan says here isn't
[ __ ] new knowledge it just is a
former [ __ ] speaker of the house
who hates Donald Trump who's always
hated Donald Trump just says just says
it out loud finally
he's fading fast he's a proven loser he
costs us the house of 18 He cusses the
White House in 20 he costs us to Senate
again and again and I think we all know
that and I think we're moving past Trump
I really okay so he's gonna stick with
the whole loser thing which I agree with
Paul Ryan he is a [ __ ] loser who
doesn't agree with it
Donald Trump is the biggest [ __ ]
loser in American politics in in modern
history
most most [ __ ] losers would
walk away and not be a loser again and
again and again sure fine
uh point taken
but this is an obvious thing
Paul Ryan's not saying anything new here
it just seems weird because he's saying
it
now Paul Ryan fails to mention what he
fails to mention is that when he lost in
2020 they continued to spread the big
lie on the [ __ ] news organization
quote news organization that he's a
board member of
to continue to spread the lie that
Donald Trump
had had [ __ ] won and Joe Biden lost
which caused the violent Insurrection on
January 6 and Nia Cheeto dust kangaroo
coup attempt
he fails to mention that he fails to
mention that the criminal president
tried to illegally
overthrow our government and [ __ ] on our
constitution nope can't mention that he
just isn't a good enough [ __ ] leader
for their party for them to win so they
can [ __ ] on the Constitution that's what
Paul Ryan means he loses we want to win
so when we win we can [ __ ] on the
Constitution when he's in charge we lose
and we don't get the [ __ ] on the
Constitution enough we hate democracy
and with him it's complicated because he
loses a lot and we can't [ __ ] on
Democracy enough that we want to let's
continue I really think that's the case
I do I can't imagine him getting the
nomination frankly he will get the
nomination
let's listen to me again I'm gonna say
it again it's January 13th Friday
uh 12 54 Eastern Time
Donald Trump
will receive the Republican nomination
who the [ __ ] is going to take it from it
you got somebody these people don't care
that he's a criminal these people don't
care that he's a crook that's a feature
they love that part they love he's
willing to do anything and commit any
crime to destroy our democracy to make
sure that people in this country do not
receive Equity Equity inequality they
want to keep their white privilege God
damn it
and he's willing to say and do anything
for them to keep their white privilege
don't you understand
he will be the the America First Nazis
party's nominee
Bet On It Paul Ryan
and I don't mean this because I don't
want to I don't want him to get the
numbers I just don't think he will as an
analytical point
the the thing that's I that I take
solace in with all the machinations you
saw last week most of that wasn't
personal most of that was around fiscal
responsibility most of that was about a
concern about spending inflation and
debt that's great I think you need to
persuade the country as to the solutions
and the problem okay he's talking about
the speaker of the house and Republicans
but that that was not that had nothing
to do about debts and deficits that is
all [ __ ] it had to do with their
individual power
to destroy our government
that's what it had to do with and Kevin
McCarthy had to sell out his entire
speakership to make sure that the Maga
caucus that these [ __ ] these [ __ ]
America First Nazis
wanted to destroy our democracy Paul
Ryan
and I don't think brinksmanship solves
those things but what's behind that is a
good thing which is Republicans finally
reacquiring their Moorings on the party
of fiscal responsibility and limited
government that to me is the good thing
that I see in all of this weird stuff
that's the good thing so the question is
can we play very positive we perform in
substances yeah well I'm a Republican
what do you want from me what do you
want from me I'm a republican I'll lie
to say anything and do any why do you
think I'm on the board of Fox News
[ __ ] Paul Ryan everyone is cheering
him like Yay he called Trump an [ __ ]
yeah Trump is an [ __ ] what what he is
a [ __ ] loser why is Paul Ryan saying
it
Paul Ryan sing
and Donald Trump a loser shouldn't be
news
Paul Ryan
giving us the truth about what he does
in the board meetings of Fox News that
might be news
I'd say that's news and um I actually
tweeted this
Paul Ryan does not know his party
and that is the full-blown truth he
doesn't know his party
no clue
sorry I'm having little um I still have
this residual little thing in the back
where it causes a cough it's like um
it feels like
do you ever feel like you have like a a
cough flap
and when the cough flap is open you just
keep getting this this thing it's when
it feels like so I get a I gotta close
the the cough flap as it that's what it
feels like it's like am I crazy
maybe I'm not crazy uh we're gonna get
Gabe Sanchez on here here in just a
minute you know it's Friday you know
what we do on Friday we do bonehead of
the week bonehead of the week where you
vote you decide for bonehead of the week
we break it down for you in the second
hour every single Friday so let's take a
break we'll be right back right after
this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
I have a cop watching
[Music]
maybe over now
hopefully Gabe Sanchez join us soon
start up the uh
bonehead of the week
oh boy
holy moly
the coffin is not gone again it feels
like there's a cough flap
all right I had sinus drainage for
everyone one no I did not test positive
for coven I had sinus drainage
yeah every once in a while this thing
happens
and it caused me to have a little bit of
a
and you can see a cough so I've been um
having the ludens and the Halls
um cough drops handy and that seems to
help
but every once in a while I get in a
situation where I feel like there's
something right here you know what I
mean I grind at the bottom of your neck
and it feels like there's a
again am I crazy
all right a cough flap and is opening or
not closing something the [ __ ] is
happening you know maybe a tickle is how
you would describe it
uh Bruce here says you need to contact
Dr Oz yeah maybe I should go uh
get advice from that loser not not
everyone's ready for bonehead here
bonetta of the week and we're gonna get
Gabe Sanchez to um
to uh join us and normally we go to like
a break and then bonehead which we'll do
it we'll do that we'll do that oh man
I try not to cough the microphone on I
apologize
winter allergies Maybe
that's probably
what caused my sinuses
yeah I have um I had this problem my
whole life you have two sets of sinuses
I guess the front the back I don't know
I'm not a doctor I don't know this [ __ ]
you go to the doctor and they tell you
this [ __ ]
but I have really large back sinuses
must be the the alpha in me
but I have really large back sinuses
apparently
and when I get drainage back there it it
lasts a lot longer so whatever
damn it
so whatever
um ailments I have with the sinuses if I
have a lot of drainage and I've had them
sinus infections before let me tell you
something
you talk about crippling headaches a
sinus infection can give you a crippling
headache
and um
my back sinuses
would be the ones to get infected when I
get them
damn it and my back sinuses would be the
ones that would get infected where is
Gabe Sanchez
let's see where he's at where are you
coughing fit
happening
get
on the air
I'm begging him come on so I can cough
so you can talk
I don't like to have dead space on my
shoe I don't like to have dead space
that's why I'm good at this I just talk
the whole time and see now if I'm in
this position it's getting better the
ring right here yeah it's good it's good
he said coming coming in now he's coming
or not Gabe said Chance is coming in hot
let's see if we can um I need to uh get
the bonehead of the week uh assets here
ready because we're going to start that
part of the show really soon you know we
knew bonehead of the week every single
every single week every single Friday
where you vote you decide for bonehead
of the week
and we break it down for you
every single Friday
we tell you why they were the bonehead
and why you probably voted for them
we add in a dishonorable mention and an
alpha cook
we have those today we have them today
um
so
Gabe Sanchez will be joining us in just
a minute to do bonehead the week I hope
oh I hope he joins us very soon
so I can hand the microphone over to him
for just a minute
oh buddy
hell
another another week
[Laughter]
oh man
oh man okay so let's let's see if we can
find one more story here before we um
go to
um
bone for the week and Gabe Sanchez
oh yes
uh Jim Jordan yeah wait I think that guy
ends up on bonehead I'll wait on that
one
you know I like the weight to hold the
bonehead stuff for the bonehead
you know what I mean
if you got bonehead material on Friday
you want to hold your bonehead material
oh Debbie here says try a humidifier is
that what's going on is it really a flap
and it's just not like humidified enough
I don't know I'm not a [ __ ] doctor
this is why this is why I don't take
advice from Facebook because I'm not a
doctor Gabe Sanchez my cough flap is
stuck
you don't want to call flap you know you
know you got a call flap you feel it
right here it gets
no it feels my cough flap is stuck over
and Debbie says uh I don't I've never
heard of a cough flap before it's a
medical thing I read it on uh there was
a Facebook group that was talking about
I should take Ivermectin I should
probably eat horse dewormer
okay I went out I mean you could try
that I I mean honestly
coughs are not healed by uh horse
dewormer it'll just give you the shits
yeah I will yeah I mean you know maybe
that'll help your cough you need an
extra Loop yeah I got illutions I got
holes here even oh okay so you go for
the Menthol I'm coming in with the I
don't know what the [ __ ] there
I don't know they're they're in a gold
bag I don't know yeah calls you know it
but it's the big guns you know it's the
ones that taste like cough drops right
right yeah glutens tastes like [ __ ]
candy yeah and again we're not sponsored
by ludens but lewton's if you're uh if
you're out there giving any corporate
sponsorships
unwrapping I'll do a little unwrapping
video for you oh [ __ ] oh no I'm glad
you're here I'm glad you're here
um because we're gonna do bone end of
the week but I found a tweet here that I
want to show everybody this is yesterday
this is Dr Rachel bittickoff for a
friend of the show and my favorite
political strategist this is what she
says about the documents thing and I
know we're going to get into it with
bonehead but she says gonna disagree
with a lot of you I think the Biden's
dock case
makes it easier not harder to hold Trump
accountable for intentional stealing
hiding and refusing to turn over
hundreds of classified docs what says
you Gabe Sanchez I agree I mean we
talked about this yesterday and It
ultimately is going to make it easier
because what it's going to show is that
Trump I mean you even had Karl Rove this
week which again it's like [ __ ] hell
froze over and this guy brought up a
whiteboard and said look let's break
down the difference between Trump and
Biden Biden found out about it the
lawyers reached out they talked to the
attorney they talked to the doj they
handed those things over
Trump
didn't tell anyone when Nara and the doj
found out they're like can we get those
things and they continue this process of
trying to evade giving them I mean to
this day they have not signed a
declaration that says we have given you
everything right keep in mind that at
the time they had uh
uh they had uh Christina Bob and they
had you know uh Jim trustee and they had
all of these other incompetent lawyers
this like Misfit lawyer group uh who
have said things on not under oath or
not under a declaration they've said
things on on Fox News and oan and
Newsmax and all this [ __ ] where
they're like oh it was just like him
taking a library book or he actually
owned those things those were his or he
Declassified them by waving the Sharpie
and with his mind if they're
Declassified then it matters if they're
deep right if there's National Security
information so it doesn't matter right
and there's all these guys that they
pile up on that exactly and so now
you're finding them stuck in a position
for two parts one of which is that they
said if you ever if anyone ever
remembers the Mueller investigation they
[ __ ] went again and again and again
that you cannot indict a sitting
president so just to push it it back on
there you cannot indict a sitting
president which Biden is actually I'll
make three points two let's say they
even do get to impeach Biden right which
wouldn't pass the Senate but let's say
it passes the house right so he gets
impeached but even if it does pass the
Senate and he does actually get removed
from office guess who's next in line
hmm who is Harris so yeah it's okay and
then the third part right here is the
idea that they want to compare be like
oh well well well it's the same thing
it's Apples to Apples when really it is
apples to oranges and it comes down to
how wait wait wait which one I I know
what you're gonna say but which one's
the Apple which one's the orange right
right so the apple is Biden and the
Orange is the orange has to be drunk
with the video we watched yesterday with
the Tanner yeah and the old leathered
orange in the sun [ __ ]
man apples oranges Apple orange I think
I think we should yeah but the third
part is it really comes back to the fact
of like the Biden Administration they
found out and they're like oh [ __ ] okay
yeah we should hand this over we will
help you we will be proactive in giving
everything you you want right and so
when Republicans are like give us the
special counsel give us a special
account they're like all right fine
within two days or so later
Garland's like all right fine here's a
special counsel this guy is part of the
federal Society he's Republican all this
[ __ ] he was speaking of Apple
Administration speaking of apples how do
you like them apples
my friend is wicked smart
but that's really what it is and it
really does like Rachel said and like we
talked about yesterday it 100 helps the
case for Biden because Biden was willing
and well not only does it help that case
but it absolutely destroys this entire
narrative around Donald Trump in these
documents because they're going to be
saying out loud like the things that are
the reason why you should prosecute
Trump for having these docs they're
going to be saying these things out loud
on their spaces that they haven't been
saying this stuff okay so on Fox news on
Newsmax they've always said the [ __ ]
lies that oh he Declassified him they're
Declassified anyways it's his [ __ ] a
president can do this and blah blah blah
you can do all this stuff but now
they're going to be saying the exact
opposite now they're going to be
directing it towards Biden but Their
audience are going to hear these things
all we have to do as a pro-democracy
coalition right is to get them to stick
and that's what Rachel's trying to tell
you Rachel's trying to say look
this makes it way easier to stick this
narrative to Trump yeah way easier to
stick this narrative to Trump the entire
country is going to hear is going to
hear why we should lock up Joe Biden for
this and then you're going to see Jack
Smith indict him on Trump right on these
things
and you're gonna go oh yeah well then he
should be locked up right right if
you're gonna show that Biden should be
locked up or impeached or whatever crime
you know oh you know we want to get rid
of him or whatever you know very vulgar
vile uh non-community guide friendly
statement you're going to make about
Biden you have to realize that you now
have to apply that same logic to the
very dude you're on your knees sucking
the orange
Clementine's for is this the difference
between apples and oranges this is
definitely I mean look okay Joe Biden's
got some apples okay and and Trump has
some little little frostbitten the
cuties yeah the cuties the ones where
you're like oh he's a little clementines
you know you know speaking of speaking
of things that don't have genitalia
genitalia and they want them to have Jan
to tell you uh let's go to bonehead of
the week because I know we're gonna get
into um Candy Candy
genitalia in the bonehead of the week so
everyone stick around we'll be right
back bone of the week right after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show Friday second
hour you know what that means bonehead
of the week you both you decide
you break it down here in the second
hour of the Tony Michaels podcast you
might go who Gabe Sanchez
Yeah Boy And of course in true style and
true fashion we got a lot of boneheads
this week
but you picked out three yeah in
particular it was kind of a rough choice
and you know there was a several of them
but one in particular yeah
um that everyone knows is a
absolute bonehead but again he's not a
standout bone he's just he just again he
he does more boneheaded things than what
the others do yeah I mean he's just not
a standout he's a stand-in right yeah
yeah maybe maybe if he's standing
apparently yeah gripping tripping over
something yeah we're gonna watch maybe
the lies I don't know it could be could
be we'll see
um here's the boneheads this week hey
you know what let's uh I'm doing this
all in the wrong order wrong order
wrong order everyone let's start the
moon end of the week here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bonehead of the week
of the week to this edition of bonehead
of the week
Eve Sanchez we have a lot of boneheads
this week we narrowed it down to three
yeah I know it's everywhere very very
hard to figure it out you know what
because you were saying who should we
put and two of them emerged and then you
were trying to figure out the other one
and I was like you know what I really
want to see if these other boneheads
beat the bonehead of the century Donald
Trump I really want to see them go
head-to-head here and that's what we did
we have representative uh George Santos
if that really is his name I'm gonna put
those in Big Air quotes there
representative
and then uh representative Kevin
McCarthy he's again barely the Speaker
of the House barely just barely I mean
you know in name only I guess some
someone called them a spino
but I feel like that would have to
assume he had a spine to begin with well
I feel like it's like a Sino a sinus
yeah yeah so there's that bonehead so
where should we start art hell let's
just start with Kevin McCarthy let's do
that why not why not he's not the winner
right no no no he did not win he did not
win well
he won speaker kind of barely yeah I
mean he didn't win last week he did
something he did that that was funny
last week because he was winning so many
votes last week yeah he was and then
finally before he won the speaker vote
he won the bonehead of the week yeah he
actually won a vote before he became
speaker it was amazing it was great I
think he was uh he was one in 12 at that
point he was one in 12 and I was
predicting no he was he was oh well I
guess he was oh and 12.
yeah he did go Owen 13. yeah he did go
with her he went he went I guess two in
15 really right because he got the bone
end of the week yeah yeah good on you
Kev you won something you [ __ ] loser
um why is he on the bonehead this week
what so there's a lot obviously uh you
could go to the house uh trying to
rescind 80 billion dollars from the IRS
that was
um given under the inflation reduction
act uh necessary upgrades and and
updates to to resources uh hiring 87 000
IRS agents over 10 years guys not all at
once no one's coming to kick down your
door the reason which they don't want
the uh their wealthy tax or their their
wealthy donors being taxed what about
this sales tax things we haven't talked
a lot about that tell me about this
national sales pushing the tax on the
sales tax
national tax on poor people because
every I don't know if people know this
or not but that's what sales tax
actually is is a tax on poor people so
the group that wants to complain about
the the gas prices and grocery prices
and inflation yeah are totally okay with
adding an additional sales tax onto
consumers so when you go buy that carton
of eggs right or that that or that that
the jug of milk or whatever it is they
want to add another tax on you right
they want to add an attack they want to
get rid of income tax they want to add
sales tax they want to help the wealthy
they want to tax the poor in the middle
class like that's ultimately what
happens here and the taxes that aren't
paid are those of the wealthy right and
they use you you will see or would see
assuming that the Senate would pass this
which they won't neither would the with
President Obama uh President Biden even
signed this thing did you almost say oh
Biden oh Biden yeah yeah right man
sometimes I just kind of think I like
having good old days you know right
right when when uh it's a big [ __ ]
deal you remember yeah yeah right that's
that truly is obiden right yeah is when
they when after after the ACA passed and
Joe Biden leans in the Barack Obama with
the hot mic he said this is a big
[ __ ] deal and um that's Joe Biden
right there and that's the thing that
Republicans want to take away uh and
have tried to take away and have you
know ultimately failed uh
and it's also the thing that you see
again and again when when Republicans
are like oh man
Healthcare is such a [ __ ] scam this
and that I just saw I just saw Pho I
actually I'll send you the tweet
but what it was it was a series of four
photos of four tweets and it was this
woman who was complaining about uh the
health care in this country and and then
she ultimately shot her own foot with
her own gun like literally like
literally shot her oh I I thought you
meant like in the tweets she oh no I
mean like she did and by tweeting it
because the person went through and
found the four tweets it's like here's a
story told in four parts and it was her
complaining her shooting herself and
then her complaining about the bills
that health care costs have by going to
the emergency room which is like of
course you know of course it's all mired
and lies and complete illusion at the
foundation of their ideology uh prime
example is this clip because I think
this is probably the most bone-headed
clip of the week from McCarthy well
they're all they're also I mean not only
this one but there also was him giving
his first kind of like press conference
in the in the uh uh
yeah this is a big one he's being
approached about George Santos right
um now George Santos is facing pressure
to resign from Congress because he lied
to his constituents about who he is
right and now he's he's it's possible
he's committed crime lying lying as a
politician no it's not possible it is is
a highly probable that he has committed
crime correct but here's the thing is is
lying to your constituents as a
politician isn't it right that's not a
crime they uh Republicans do it every
day I mean every single thing that pukes
out of their mouth is a [ __ ] lie
um so it really is funny when um he's
asked this Kevin McCarthy's asked this
question here and he goes straight to
Crime which is hilarious yeah that this
is the thing that's in the Forefront of
all Republicans Minds is crime well
let's listen
call on him to resign today does that
affect your thinking at all what do you
intend to do about Congressman Santos I
try to stick by the Constitution the
voters elected him to serve
if there is a concern he has to go
through the ethics we'll let him move
through that but right now the voters
have have a voice in the decision it's
not where people pick and choose based
upon what somebody's press has so he
will continue to serve are you going to
take any action against him at this
point or any of these allegations
acceptable to you what are the charges
against him
even even if even if there are even if
there are charges even if there were
charges you're still by the Constitution
you're Presumed Innocent yeah proven
guilty but the the mere fact that
they're sitting here talking to Kevin
mcgarth like hey constituents the county
Republicans are pissed off that this guy
lied about who he is right not not
exactly about the crimes right because
that's going to be a whole nother story
the crimes he committed in the lies he
told may have a little bit to do with
each other but they they in most of his
lies he's not committing crime he's just
a [ __ ] liar he's a republican what do
you want from him I mean that is what
they are right that is within their
their DNA but it's hilarious that inside
that DNA is cooked where Kevin McCarthy
absolutely has to go to well is he
charged or is it crime crime crime is
the first thing
because they know in case he was saying
Kevin McCarthy isn't Dumb and oblivious
to what's going on he's literally
following and I'm sure he has AIDS that
are like trying to track down
information if they can find it before
the Press does oh at every single term
Mother Jones Washington Post
uh New York Times They all reported on
Santos on different stories all
surrounding his financial
mystery and shadiness okay so just keep
that in mind that different Publications
were reporting about Santos and his
Shady dealings on three different things
from whether he got it where he got his
money who gave him the money how much
they gave him the different people but
the other thing here is it is funny how
immediately they will go to oh well
what's the crime right like oh oh hold
on hold on hold on back up here uh we
never brought up the crime and the idea
that you want to immediately go well
that's for the Ethics Committee the very
Ethics Committee that they've that they
voted on to gut which George Santo says
oh that sounds fantastic we shouldn't do
that yeah we should totally get the
after this committee if there especially
they're going to investigate me right
like I don't want the people I I wanna
like because not only that but remember
it's they wanted to they wanted to put
the special subcommittee the the
weaponization of the federal government
to investigate the investigators who are
investigating them for the crimes that
they committed and the same thing goes
here is
uh having a very um ethical party that
they claim to be they're going to gut
the very office that would investigate
people and groups for violations of
ethics
sounds very republican-like sounds
pretty on par for the Republicans
they they are criminals they are that
brings us
to our next bonehead of the week uh
Donald Trump because we put him we put
him on there for the video that he did
right the absolute just
shitty diaper rant that he did that we
went over yesterday and we'll play a
little bit of it here but we've had news
since that happened this morning
um they are officially a crime family
not only have they been charged with 17
counts of fraud but they've been
sentenced uh as it were Alan weissenberg
the CFO is going to serve five months in
rankers which is probably like 50 years
to be honest with you I mean it's not
enough yeah yeah but it's I will hear
his thing at age 75 five months in
Rikers it ain't gonna be uh it ain't
gonna be a nice trip listen being La I
would not want to be locked up in Rikers
for a minute uh and a day would probably
seem like a month in Rikers because of
the situation there but it's still it's
not enough for uh Alan weiselberg and
really honestly if Donald Trump ever
gets convicted of crimes I think we
should just give him life and Rikers
that would be yeah he probably wouldn't
survive six months I would assume you're
going to tell the audience this morning
is that um the Trump organization is a
criminal organization this morning in
that they are being forced by a judge to
pay not near enough but 1.61 million
dollars
um towards restitution to the state of
New York for defrauding them in tax
schemes and hiding money and hiding uh
taxes that they owed to the state which
again I I don't think is enough now that
is why you have the Attorney General of
New York uh Tish James bringing a civil
case there's a lot lower bar and there's
a lot different laws when you're
actually happening to pay restitution in
those ways this was the max number one
just to know that the judge didn't go
light on Donald Trump and his criminal
organization and his crime family
by only finding them 1.61 million
um he didn't go light on that's the max
he could give him so he gave him the
absolute highest dollar he could pop by
New York law that he could possibly find
them is that the way you understand it
yeah that's the way that I look at it
and the other thing I want to add and
I'm going to send to this clip right now
is as much as you know Alvin Bragg
really dropped the ball on this right he
wants to be like oh well this wasn't
clearly enough and all this [ __ ] he
could have done a better job at
following through with this however
in this clip it makes it sound like
there is going to be more right so it
sounds like there's like we already know
about Tish James and her investigation
right that's a 250 million dollar
lawsuit against Trump the Trump org and
his three adult children
so here that this who this is Alan Bragg
standing at the podium and and and this
is after you know the judges ordered the
1.16 million dollars let's take a listen
the sentencing today along with the
sentence interview this week
closes this important chapter of our
ongoing investigation into the former
president uh businesses
thank you you stay closer to chapter can
you use Alan weisselberg again to pursue
Mr Trump so the way that I see this is
It's potentially discussing a whole
separate phase of this investigation
right because he's very careful about
how he says that right right Aaron Bragg
is very measured which most prosecutors
are in these moments if it's a big
moment like this when he says closing
this chapter moving on to the next
chapter which maybe maybe Alan Bragg is
throwing his weight to Tish James yeah
you know I don't know or maybe they are
considering
um continuing some sort of Investigation
I mean we know with Trump there's always
a crime that's been committed right the
guy wakes up and he's criming let's
let's honestly how he works and it's not
just one it's like one at a time yeah oh
yeah it's he crimes and then he crimes
to cover up the crime and then he crimes
the crime this government the crime like
I'm like he throws ketchup at the wall
right exactly like the crimes that Trump
commits is like a Russian nesting doll
like you pick one you're like oh there's
a crime within that crime that the crime
was covering up for the previous crime
right and that is exactly what's
happened here and I and I honestly think
that right well at least I hope is when
he says next chapter
that he's discussing something that
isn't isn't privy to the public right I
mean he might have maybe he maybe he's
referring to Tish James but there's a
part of me that's assuming that he's
actually talking about something else
right well I don't believe that Alan
Bragg would actually um especially in
public uh give way for Tish James in a
civil suit right he would he would want
that notch on his belt that's what
prosecutors ultimately do that's what
you have to remember about Jack Smith or
anyone else is they want a notch on
their belt uh even in this Biden
documents thing they're going to want a
notch but if they can't get a notch they
can't get it speaking of
um
notches
um look at this ass crack holy moly this
is another reason why this uh the cheese
it looks like a weather belt it's but
this is real yeah I didn't edit this
that's right this is part of the video
he looks like um what did you say the
other day an old piece of leather laying
out in the sun the floor yeah I said uh
it looks yeah like an old piece of
leather that had been laying out in the
Florida Sun aged
beyond belief it was not aging well it
reminds me of that woman in Florida
who's you know got the like bleach
blonde hair from the Sun and frazzled
and the sun take off the sunglasses and
you see like uh a big white area here
and lines across and you look at her
skin and it's it it looks like like beef
jerky like it looks like something like
a saddle right you throw on a horse oh
yeah I'm not gonna listen to this whole
thing but um I want to get to a certain
point because there's a point in this
video
where he says something that is just
[ __ ] hilarious and makes you laugh
out loud because you just want to mock
him so much that he's even projecting
his own wishes that how his cult will
see him
um it's hilarious watch the now famous
Twitter files have proven beyond all
doubt that the corrupt officials at the
FBI have been coordinating a massive
censorship surveillance and propaganda
campaign against the American people and
frankly against me why why does it
always seem like he just had an enema
like he just like like he's preparing he
had to prepare for this thing
you know
he's like the announcement of family
good famous Twitter fast
uh I mean it's it it it looks like
they had to give him like a suppository
to really get him woke up with them I
know he's like okay I'm telling you or
like or maybe it's like a a coffee enema
right I don't know the caffeine beans
are hitting this colon oh the beans in
the butt the cosafe beans are hitting
the colon baby oh the butt stuff ah
definitely looks like that's going on
with this guy
um let's continue here because I want to
get to this funny part let's get to it
in the most recent and notorious example
the FBI worked to stop the truth from
being told about the Biden family's
criminality they work so hard to stop it
from coming out and the corruption prior
to the 2020 election they didn't want
any bad information to come out about
the Biden family the fix was in the
election was rigged but the censorship
of the laptop from hell is only the
beginning of the story about the
weaponization of government against Free
Speech we must have free speech in our
country we must have a fair and Free
Press as recent reporting shows the FBI
and other Rogue agencies have been
systematically colluding with former
National Security officials placed in
high positions at Twitter and very
likely other companies to advance their
censorship regime which is really in
this case to steal an election this
anti-American effort and a very illegal
effort at that has been working to
silence dissenting opinions on covet and
crucial issues on public health and on
the election and elections in the future
they suppress doctors and health experts
who dared to question approved Public
Health narratives they censored voices
who criticized school closures lockdowns
and mandates and they even banned people
simply for stating proven scientific
facts and anything bad about China they
didn't want out but anything bad about
biting and the Biden crime family and
that's what it was just look at the
laptop from hell they didn't want that
coming out under any circumstances what
they wanted coming out was anything bad
about your favorite President me
that's the best part well they didn't
want yeah
about your favorite President me me like
it's hilarious that he thinks the
audience knows who the favorite
President is but he still has to say I
mean if we if anyone remembers like he
did the same thing when he released his
digital trading cards he was like look
hopefully hopefully guys I'm making this
video because I'm [ __ ] broke
hopefully guys uh You Love Me Maybe I'm
your favorite President like uh George
Washington or Abraham Lincoln it's
better he no he said he was better than
them right better yeah I'm way better
than that I'm better he's like hopefully
hopefully meanwhile he's trying to push
the the idea of get a free dinner with
me or you pay 99 for dinner what's
hilarious is this guy this this [ __ ] box
this [ __ ] shitty diaper running
around you know being a Scourge on our
democracy actually believes that somehow
someway someday that his face is going
to be carved in around Mount Rushmore
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
this guy uh he could literally be on our
bonehead list every single week he
really could every single week
um and I believe that that video where
he's talking about the Biden crime
family he knew they were going to be
sentenced the next day he knew they were
going to pay the maximum Vine he knew it
was going to make him look like a
criminal because he is they are the
Trump crime family that is what they are
these are the facts
Trump speak it's projecting something
that he has done some illegal some some
crime he has committed some crime and
he's doing whenever he complains about
something he's actually subconsciously
uh admitting to the crime that he
himself or his family have done right he
wants to [ __ ] and moan about Biden
having documents that Biden worked in in
and cooperated with the
the FBI and the attorney and uh handing
the documents over and then you know
he's oh we joked about yesterday but I
believe Trump will ultimately uh just
admit to the crime of stealing the
documents that weren't actually his to
prove that he had the better crime right
right he stole the better my documents I
stole them better and they were nobody
could steal them better than me right
exactly exactly because he is the
perfect criminal ah speaking
of people who are [ __ ] boxes this
[ __ ] guy for Alpha cook oh boy God
okay so this
here's a video that this guy released
Nick Adams
um he claims he's an alpha male we call
them Alpha cucks here because if you
have to Proclaim you're an alpha male he
even said this if you have to Proclaim
your novel mail then you're not one even
though the same account proclaims a
anyways this guy is a douche canoe
now this I don't know if he flew all the
way to New York to do this video
um well you have to remember that this
is a whole story dude this whole Saga
because Tucker Carlson works his way
into this story yeah apparentlyn so
let's start let's rewind back a little
bit to figure out how we got to M M's
and genitalia because Gabe Sanchez that
is the real question that I have here do
M M's have dicks that is with this
segment here on the the bone of the week
figure out the new segments have dicks I
just want to know this just a Breaking
News segment do M M's have dicks I just
want to know okay some of these people
think they do so I want to find figure
this out so the uh
let me just get this link for you so
this is a video so three months ago back
in October this is where it all starts
whoa whoa whoa this is a long time let's
reel it back for everyone back in
October of 2022 mm-hmm
Ms or the Mars Mars Incorporated the
Mars company uh comes out and they say
hey we're coming out with a brand new
colored Eminem this is October 2nd this
is October September 2nd
it's a purple peanut
purple peanut m m okay it's a spokes
candy I think it's the name does it have
genitalia does it have genitalia now
that's the question of the century well
that's what the right wing wants to know
and they want to know they yes they are
obsessed with uh what's going what's
behind that Chocolate shell is it a dick
or is it not oh my god well does this
clip give us any sense that if Eminem
have have dicks does this clip do that
or should we just watch it and see what
just watch it and see and see what comes
out of it Eminem's you know the candy we
all grew up eating well they released
their brand new character in over a
decade and the brand new character is
purple Eminem which is supposed to
represent inclusivity and acceptance
I think it's a female character but I'm
pretty sure they haven't said maybe it's
transgender joining me now
question is this is specific I'm not
being misogynistic here yeah this is the
reason why I'm being specific here on do
M M's have dicks is because they're
obsessed with dicks they're obsessed
with it like he's like oh it could be a
girl but maybe it has a wiener like
that's what he's trying to say and
they're secretly hoping like I hope it
does I hope it yeah because at the end
of the day these Republicans like and
and I'm working on a what was that for
this because it is honestly so insane
Fox News has a much deeper history with
their sexualization of M Ms specifically
the green m m way uh way before Tucker
Carlson right now should we should we no
I'm not gonna play the I'm not gonna
play the um the green Eminem Tucker yeah
yeah can you find me the clip of um
Tucker talking about this purple Eminem
story because we know he we know he was
obsessed with sexy M M's so Tucker
definitely may or may not want yeah we
know all about that and like I said
there's a whole other aspect to it which
I'm working on that reveals I mean Ben
Shapiro even went uh
on his show to to to reuse the same
misogynistic transphobic joke oh really
yeah that he that he went on and it was
to uh to bash women right with single
women at home with drinking their wine
eating their chocolate candy with their
cats what does this have to do with M
M's again well it's you know it's like
oh this is the first female he made some
jokes about uh women and then also made
jokes about like oh this is the first
female uh Eminem with a pair of nuts you
know and it's oh I see yeah okay okay I
see the same idea but again but at the
end he was like oh I wouldn't ask female
M M's where to drive or like directions
like very misogynistic stereotypes about
women right well and that's why this
again my question today on this part of
the bone end of the week is do M M's
have dicks maybe Tucker Carlson in this
14 second clip can tell us if M M's have
wieners or not let's listen woke M M's
have returned
green m m got her boots back but
apparently is now a lesbian maybe and
there's also a plus-sized obese purple m
m so we're going to cover that of course
because that's what we do okay because
that's what we do do we cover we cover
woke him and him literally
Tucker Carlson he is the highest rated
Fox News show and this guy is doing sexy
Eminem bits oh man the only reason why
we get the laugh at this is because
they're so stupid they're like it is so
easy to make fun of them when Tucker
Carlson keep in mind just earlier this
week okay we had a [ __ ] sequel a
shitty sequel to The Insurrection in
Brazil okay
yeah it was it was a fake one because it
wasn't really and Fox News doesn't
really cover it right what they do is
they talk about how this and I and I kid
you not Tony
the uh the Fox News crew the morning
program
uh wanted to talk about how this is
actually a Chinese psyop which one the M
Ms are the in the female defeat no well
yeah instead of talking about the
Insurrection which is like a day prior I
think they're talking about the Eminem
we're talking about how the purple the
the purple the female M M's are actually
a Chinese psyop that they're pushing
through Tick Tock to distract people
from the real issues the real issues not
that Republicans are talking about M M's
or gas stoves or uh any any other uh
we're gonna give you any trivial
problems they don't want to talk about
the real things that's that's a psyop
yeah yeah
oh my God okay well maybe this guy is a
psyop because here here is the here is
part of this morning story on this on
the do M M's have dicks
um questions
I might be breaking news I don't know
um this is Nick Adams the quote uh
self-proclaimed alpha male which
according to him does not make you an
alpha male but he says in this tweet I'm
done with Eminem's not one Eminem's will
pass my lips until Mars formal apology
and releases an all-male package of M
M's there's a video that goes along with
this don't worry audience to demonstrate
their commitment to General equality why
would I bring evidence if M M's have or
don't have dicks without a video we
gotta have video evidence here yeah um
he goes on to say these female M M's are
a slap in the face to men everywhere
Jesus Christ I just I just want to point
out that when you when you get to the
second part of that not one Eminem will
pass my lips until Mars issues a formal
apology and releases an all-male package
of Eminem's to demonstrate their
commitment to gender equality well here
sounds kind of erotic it is yeah he's
writing he's writing some a certain type
of porn here
um now I I commented this is my comment
because this is what it sounds like to
me in the video and maybe the audience
can tell me because we're trying to
figure out today and this part of bone
end of the week rather M M's have dicks
Nick here only wants male M M's to melt
in his mouth and not in His Hands that's
what he's saying right he won't eat a
female m m yeah he's done he's done with
the female M M's does not want them to
melt in his mouth and not in his hand
here is the video that goes along this
[ __ ] asshat went to New York City
that's where this is at right outside
yep you can see the M M's right there
what what is this is it like an Eminem
store or some [ __ ] I don't know it seems
like a big m m store honestly because
it's near Times Square
he's not actually going to the Mars Inc
or Wrigley Factory which is back in
Chicago okay he really wanted to
complain about this he would go to
Chicago which if you go to Chicago yeah
but he didn't it's I can tell you from
experience the building is like just a
manila like colored built like it just
breaks right
oh you're nearby because you can smell
the chocolate listen if you expect this
guy to know anything real about Mars or
M M's he doesn't even know Eminem's
don't have [ __ ] genitalia he has no
clue he's looking at him and getting him
out of the backers looking for the fight
he's looking for the dick Jesus he is
looking for the dick I I'm I promise you
listen to this
video
g'day guys Nick Adams here I want to
speak about Eminem's I want to speak
about Mars the company behind Eminence M
M's have just released feminist Eminems
Yes you heard me right feminist Eminence
egregious sexism of the worst and most
conceivable kind oh my God can you
imagine can you imagine Gabe Sanchez the
worst the worst
crime and history against against
someone's gender it's almost like that a
certain gender would make less money
just because they had a certain
genitalia in this country for a certain
period of time or some [ __ ] it's almost
like they still do today or something I
mean I honestly if we could get an
Agatha Christie style who'd done it you
know so that he could identify that it
was the woke left mob a bunch of antifa
feminists
socialist people and he goes ah I see
that's the one they they are the ones
who committed the crime oh my God this
guy let's let's continue because he
talks maybe he says maybe he confirms it
for us here he went into the m m store
and confirms that yes in fact Eminem's
do have dicks because that is the
question let's see come on Nick Adams
tell us
I just
write complete and total boycott of all
things Mars and particularly M M's it
will not stand let me say this loudly
let me say this clearly let me say this
unambiguous any mile that buys a packet
of M M's
male feminist
who has serious serious problems
until Eminem's Rectify this grave Wrong
by giving us all male Eminem
okay so first off this is such a [ __ ]
joke what oh my God you couldn't you
can't make parody better than this
listen my name is Nick Adams and I want
to say loudly clearly and unambiguously
that only beat us
a Eminem's especially all female
Eminem's like that's that's what like
the ones with dicks oh my God the ones
with the tiny little chocolate dicks
I mean literally literally he doesn't
understand that the marketing characters
that are the M M's that you see yeah
that have human qualities
and possible gender because the voices
of them are gender yeah all of them
until recently with the green Eminem
were men they were all males they were
all men you [ __ ] Tweed
she says Christ the green Eminem was
intro and like I said earlier Fox News
is the whole thing back in 2008 or
whatever but the green m m came out
around Valentine's Day back in 2008
right it's so they were all men until
then they were all men until men all
right and now he's pissed off that
there's two two female or three I guess
there's three now because they say the
greatest act against men they must be
lesbians because they they don't look
like they have sex with the male M Ms
because the male Eminem's are alpha
males and everyone knows that women
absolutely are disgusted by alpha male
so why would the would the female M M's
Jesus only beat us
chocolate female
it's a beta only betas where chocolate M
M's that are female but hold on wait
wait wait oh you gotta play the end of
that video oh is there an is there a
better part to the end there's the
better part because this is what I
believe is the best part and it and it
shows you
the same when he gets the bag out when
he goes yeah yeah yeah cause that's a I
think that's the most important part
because what it shows you
is that that guy Nick Adams Nick Adams
uh uh what a good day everyone my name's
Nick Adams and I'm here because I got a
small dick and uh I'm insecure about
these chocolate M M's having a very big
money oh my God but if you go to the end
of the video here you watch him do the
same thing that conservatives and anyone
who's having a tantrum
will always do
okay let's let's watch this part
we will not stand for this at all
M M's
[Laughter]
so okay so he buys a bag of M M's he
bought a bag of M M's from the m m store
he won't put him in his mouth because he
doesn't want the female M M's in his
mouth this whole boycott thing it sounds
and we've heard it before we got a
boycott Coke we got a boycott Pepsi
we've got a boycott Home Depot we got a
boycott the boycott the MLB we got a
boycott Harry Styles like all of these
things what it really translates to is
I'm triggered by something that you did
which is you maybe spoke out against
some injustice that makes you woke right
uh you spoke out and defended this group
with this marginalized Community because
God forbid somebody helps out their
former human like that's pretty
offensive to do that Gage I know I know
but then what they do is they say I'm
gonna boycott which translates to I'm
Gonna Cancel you guys I'm canceling you
guys right the ant the the anti-cancel
culture group of people we're gonna get
to that with the gas stoves here it and
so when you see them they do this every
time they buy the product that they vow
to boycott and cancel from the very
company that they despise and say
they're woke so in that example he
walked into the m m store
he walked into the m m store and most
likely had to pay an up charge because
it's in Times Square so he went to New
York and he gave the money directly to
Eminem he gave directions no third party
right it went from Nick Adams to his
tiny little Alpha cuck wallet into the
bank account of Mars Inc okay
Mars Inc did they change their name
already well here's a story that he
tweeted out this morning which I said it
has Santos energy uh really high Santos
energy and I said the narrator this
never happened
here's the story he tweeted this I was
that can you actually you know what I'm
I'm gonna let you read it in his voice
go ahead okay
uh Nick Adams Alpha mile Nick Adams and
USI fours ago I was at a bodega this
morning when a small boy asked his
mother for some candy as I saw her hand
reach for the package of him names I
cried out and left my place in line to
stop her
once I informed her Eamon Amos had a
gone woke
she thanked me profusely and opted for
tweaks instead
this never happened this did not happen
uh can you can you tell me can you tell
me
um
who makes Twix I
I would bet Nick Adams doesn't know who
makes Twix but I would bet
are we talking left tweaks or right
clicks which which side of the Twix are
you asking who makes what you know what
I'll tell you here look who makes the
left Twix who makes the left Twix is it
Mars it's Mars
he didn't even have the [ __ ]
whereworth all the Google who made Twix
um look my favorite honestly one of my
favorite go-to candies are the peanut M
Ms I think they're great because they're
not too chocolatey
that's the ones I usually go to like if
I go to movie theater I'm like I'll get
some popcorn and I'll get like peanut M
M's and I love Twix too but the idea
that this [ __ ] idiot was like oh man
this grave Injustice is about to be
committed because this woman is about to
buy her own child a bag of candy
chocolate M M's because these fictional
characters with their imaginary penises
like Mr Potato Head I gotta freak out
get out of line at a bodega while I'm in
New York buying candy and then tell this
woman no no don't buy those chocolate
peanut M M's don't you dare buy those M
M's what you should buy is the Twix yeah
the woke Twix they'll give you a clap
here let me give you a clap here now
here's the other thing Twix I'm look
look all I'm saying is Twix also seem to
uh
look familiar to a certain shape Tony
I'm just saying
it doesn't it doesn't add the Snicker
veins on it though it doesn't have the
Snicker paints but it does have some it
kind of has a little roller looks like
it's got some kind of rib thing on it
yeah it's got and it there's not just
one right I mean you could you could hey
you could have at the both same time
both at the same time if you want but
what I'm saying is there's not just one
there's two so
you know um I I wanna I wanna apologize
to the audience we tried really hard to
look for evidence uh if M M's have dicks
on them and if they have genitalia not
at all really but Dick's in particular
it turns out this morning it turns out
that we were you know look I said the
whole team I sent the whole team to
Chicago to go into the lab where they
make it the woke lab where the mother
wokers make the woke candy which turns
out that candy doesn't uh they don't
have genitalia they can't reproduce the
way that humans and animals can uh you
know what I think you know I think
because Mars is brilliant about this
because yeah they've been playing
footsies with these idiots for a while
and you know the only way
it's almost a year to the day by the way
January 21st yeah but do you look at the
[ __ ] package when you go into theater
and you open the M M's and you [ __ ]
start eating them no no very rarely
actually you know what I do I look at
the packaging and then I look at the
characters and I go I'm eating you you
little [ __ ] and then I eat it and I go
you're never gonna have any little m m
babies trying to trying to get rid of
your sexy boots and stop turning me on
how dare you wear those high heel white
boots God damn it I want the sexy boots
I need to be turned on when I'm looking
at my candy packaging these people are
[ __ ] dumb Eminems don't have dicks
folks they don't have dicks but Mars is
brilliant by by absolutely baiting these
idiots and everyone paying attention to
their packaging because here we are
giving Eminem a 20 minute free
commercial oh my god of the day it just
goes to show you and I'm sure you're
about to jump into this this story yes
but it just goes to show you that when
Fox and Republicans have nothing to talk
about like the fact that they passed uh
they passed
a bill in the house representative that
went against the IRS that so they didn't
have to tax wealthy people they passed
bills that went against women's
Reproductive Rights again will not pass
the Senate will not touch the desk of
Joe Biden he will never sign it it's all
performative past a deal where that
where they tax poor people into Oblivion
with sales and the idea that they're
going to pass all this legislation it's
never going to go anywhere but it's a
distraction just like they wanted to
talk about peanut M M's and genitalia
and wokism and all this [ __ ] after
the January 8th was it January 8th
Insurrection attempt at the Insurrection
sequel in in Brazil
a day after oh yeah it was the eighth on
Sunday and the day after on the ninth
they were already talking about what is
a three-month-old story
right to refocus and distract you or at
least their demographic and their base
onto something that's just trivial
unimportable no news well there's more
of it in the news but it's the opposite
way
you're gonna have to pry these things
they're gonna boycott and cancel M Ms
with penises well without penises excuse
me
they want the candy we want today they
want and they want to sell it to
Children right so they're gonna they're
gonna boycott and cancel for sure
Eminem's Without wieners but
when it comes to gas stoves get your
grubby little hands off my gas stove and
the depth brings us to this dishonorable
mention of Matt Getz because I believe
he posted a video but there's a lot of
dishonorable mentions here in this line
of [ __ ] boxes on this gas stove thing
now yeah here's the story
there's actually two things outside of
this gaster there's another there's a
clip with another one of our people that
were on the show this week that I want
to bring up okay uh it's it's a it's a
longer it's like a seven minute segment
but this is just a clip of it
um
oh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and so
yeah so Matt gatz posted a video of the
gas stove and the burners on
and he says pry it out of my cold dead
hands as if it's a gun yeah Jim Jordan
I'm gonna show you the [ __ ] picture
of this him tweeting Jim Jordan tweeted
God Guns gas stoves now here's where
this derives from because he get they
got rid of the babies huh I guess so you
know [ __ ] [ __ ] uh [ __ ] the babies yes
those are more important apparently they
want a constitutional amendment so they
can um
um you know bear their gas stoves now
here's the thing
the reason why this is even a story
is because the federal government has
oversight over Private Industry in
consumer protection okay it's a thing a
lot of products especially products that
are designed for children toys
um all kinds of [ __ ] uh safety devices
like like a booster seat or a car seat
or a stroller they all go through ex
excruciating
um testing to make sure I don't know
they don't injure or kill Oh you mean
there's like some regulatory agency that
has to make sure oh correct this is safe
and this isn't there's all kinds there's
also there's also regular agencies for
appliances cars there's all sorts of
yeah to make sure that almost like the
government is looking out for the best
interest and well-being of I don't know
it's citizens it is us we are the
government we should uh you know make
sure we're keeping each other safe now
in that effort they do many studies one
of the studies
is about uh the leading cause of carbon
monoxide poisoning in the home
now if anyone knows what carbon monoxide
is it's the exhaust from certain gases
being burnt um when I was a kid we had
propane I lived on a farm
we didn't have a gas line that came all
the way out to our [ __ ] farm so we
had this big ass tank out in the yard
big huge [ __ ] tank it was painted
white and in that tank they would put
propane and that would run our water
heater and our furnace now we we didn't
run the furnace a lot because propane
was [ __ ] expensive so we had a wood
stove that we mainly heated the house
our propane furnace was our backup but
we used it to heat water all the time
that's how we that's how the the water
heater would run was off propane
um and when you have those sorts of
appliances in your house there's the
potential for leaks of carbon monoxide
from these poisonous gases because they
burn really well they burn really
efficient that's why we use them in like
stoves water heaters and furnaces
but they can kill you they can kill you
if you're not I don't know being safe
so they did a study Gabe Sanchez and can
you guess can you guess the one leading
cause for carbon monoxide poisoning for
children what Appliance cause carbon
monoxide poisoning in children in homes
across the U.S I don't know if if I had
to throw something out there like I
wasn't even using any sort of deductive
reasoning uh I would say it was the oven
gas stoves yeah it was gas stoves it was
gas stoves um so immediately when this
um report comes out the administration
is not calling to ban gas stoves they're
again this is just a report for
consumers to know and the suggestion in
the report was hey if you really are
concerned that you are at high risk for
carbon monoxide poisoning this is the
leading cause of it in your home to kill
you and your children and and and
elderly folks as well
is the gas stove that's the leading
cause so you can do two things you can
either a not have a gas stove right that
would eliminate this possibility or B
get a upgraded gas stove or C get take
higher precautions like I don't know a
carbon monoxide detector that way
there's another carbon monoxide in the
air it will detect it or beep beep beep
beep beep you'll know it you'll know not
to be in the house because it's also I
mean for people who don't know carbon
monoxide is known as a silent killer
yeah it'll kill you in sleep exactly you
won't wake up yeah now
of course in true style and fashion they
believe the cancer culture folks the M
Ms got dicks thing
they believe that this is canceling gas
does and they're going to take away your
gas stoves not anything in the report
said anything about that it just said if
you don't want the risk here's how you
can eliminate it getting rid of them is
the easiest well is the
is the one that will eliminate the risk
the most because it if you have electric
instead of gas you don't have the risk
of killing yourself in your sleep right
but they immediately
because I and again this is all really
[ __ ] stupid
but what do you expect from people who
think M Ms should have dicks
um I'm dead serious this is yeah and so
Jim Jordan um posts this
now let me see if I can find this
because this is this is while you find
while you find that uh there is a little
history lesson and I think I've talked
about it once before uh on the show
which was if people don't know there was
a there was a suicide
um
the rate of suicide in the UK used to be
significant used to be significantly
higher
um you know early on 20s 30s everything
like that and the UK uh their you know
government government uh discovered that
the reason was because of
coal gas right so people were you know
open in the oven putting their head in
getting this cold gas which carbon
monoxide straight died right and what
they ultimately discovered was hey for
the public health
concern that we have right now what
we're going to do is we're going to with
tech the technology that is Advanced
we're going to now replace the ovens
right we're not going to say why because
the end goal was they wanted to impact
the suicide rate and what they saw was
there was a negative there was a decline
in suicides once they switched over to
uh gas stoves not coal stoves and
actually proved that they were actually
they were able to help uh the the public
by reducing the amount of suicides that
were happening in the UK
eliminate the risk because they couldn't
use God forbid a government actually
does something to help the well-being of
people because Republicans surely don't
want to
well here is Jim Jordan in true [ __ ]
vile fashion and again I think it's
really telling after what we just said
about you know they're trying to protect
children mainly in the home from this
silent killer as you call it because
children are smaller body weight and it
takes less of the carbon monoxide to
kill them you [ __ ] boneheads
um and you think they would kind of be
able to decipher some of that stuff
probably not because they're morons but
here's the thing Jim Jordan literally
takes God Guns babies right because
they're all concerned about abortions
and murdering babies blah blah blah they
even pass the bill this week that would
suggest that people are are aborting
babies after they're born which is not a
thing that's called Murder because
they're now born they are now people
anyways
he takes the baby out of the phrase
because the baby's death the grass
killed the baby well yeah right so and
he puts in the gas stove God Guns gastos
this is [ __ ] this is absolute the the
most hilarious political theater I have
ever seen in my life even more than the
Eminem stuff that number one they
believe that somehow the government's
gonna come get your gas stove because
Ronnie Jackson had one as well something
like Pride out of my cold dead hands or
something stupid which I think is
hilarious because the idea that okay
well not only is that ridiculous but
let's just quickly back up Jim Jordan
his legacy will be a Kanye tweet
not reporting sex crimes is subcommittee
that a God that's going to prove nothing
and also this gas dove comment because
at the end of the day they're all idiots
but what I will say is this idea that
you're going to tell someone you gotta
grab it out of my cold dead hands first
off if you're trying to grab a stove
especially a burner while it's on or was
just on you're an idiot and and I
honestly think that Republicans will and
I honestly think that Republicans are
going to turn all their gas burners on
on a stove
and shut the windows and Heat their
house that way I apologize it was not I
think Ronnie Jackson said this too but
this is Matt gas yeah yeah but the idea
that and he has a video and it's just
him watching a burner go which is like
okay yeah sure I'm you're you're you
know you're spending pennies right now
to pay for this gas
uh but the idea that someone's gonna Co
like the pry the whole oven or probably
just the burner that's what I want to
know and if it's the burner
these people are [ __ ] idiots you try
to grab something that was just that you
know what [ __ ] it I'm not even gonna
tell him not to do it just go do it just
go get just go grab the burner can I
tell you what this is about yeah okay so
I said I grew up on a farm and that I
had that propane
um and I would bet if you look at the
statistics of gasoline or excuse me gas
stoves either propane or natural gas
depending on how that gas is brought
into the house
I would almost bet
and if you look at the numbers of that
and the Republicans did
of how many gas stoves are in rural
areas versus non-rural areas I would bet
that the percentage of gas stoves and
rural areas is very high because
generally speaking
it um it they are very high in rural
areas and Commercial settings almost a
lot of commercial stoves a lot of
commercial
um cooking apparatuses appliances Ovens
pizza ovens there's all sorts of them
are all uh done by gas a lot of them and
and the reason why is because and Gabe
probably knows this better than I do
um is because his family's been in the
restaurant business is that it's because
it's a very consistent heat electric is
not a consistent heat so it a lot of
people like to cook with gas because it
is you can control it better almost and
also there's a vent you know right right
right but um but that that is so it's in
a lot of commercial settings so gas
stoves are not going anywhere yeah
they're not the most of the food that
you go out and you eat a lot of it is
cooked with a gas stove now the reason
why the Republicans are doing this is
because real white people own gas stoves
and if if they can convince rule white
people that the government is going to
come knock on their door and force them
to hand over their gas stove they will
get pissed off about it they will start
making social media posts about it they
will start posting pictures saying Pride
out of a cold day in hands and they will
start tweeting God's guns gas stoves I
mean literally this is a simple outrage
that does not exist that they're trying
to make it exist inside of their
constituency and it is white supremacy
is what their that's who they're
speaking to the same [ __ ]
who hate the LGBT community who are
showing up and terrorizing the LGBT
community who are calling hospitals
Children's Hospitals terrorizing them
because they hate lgbtq people this is
the same stupid female male Eminem [ __ ]
that's all it is is fake [ __ ] outrage
for people they [ __ ] hate and and get
people to hate others it's all stoking
of hate and it's dumb and stupid and
also makes sense and not only does it
not make any sense but it's also a group
of people they're attacking that don't
care anything to do with them they these
people from the LGBT community or
wherever or other people from minority
groups they don't care about Republicans
in the sense of they they don't want to
know what they're doing in their life
they don't care what's going on their
home but the opposite is true of
Republicans their projection of
genitalia gender uh you know uh trans
Community gay community
right you know [ __ ] it's what you know
again crimes I mean
Eminem's in their and their fear is
rooted in transphobia and it's rooted in
their own insecurity and that insecurity
is what drives them to push away and and
uh and say oh these people are taboo and
we shouldn't like them who shouldn't be
with them we're pure we're white we're
straight we're this we're that you're
not you're bad you have now been ousted
from the community that is what they
care about they only care to be within
their own group their own Echo chamber
and that's all that Republicans do is
they just continue to bounce off the
same Silo of each other and Echo the
same same points in agreement and have
confirmation bias oh yeah you know what
it's the [ __ ] the M M's are turning
people gay it's the rainbow in the M Ms
it's like you guys won't take my gas
Dove out of my cold dead hands right and
here's the thing here's the craziest
part going back to the gas stoves
is the government report where they're
trying to convey the information that
hey the leading cause of carbon monoxide
death
is these gas stoves yeah
and Republicans know that their
constituency is the one who has the
highest percentage of likelihood of
owning these white rural people
the government's trying to help and
provide information to those people to
help save their lives possibly and the
Republicans are like nope nope [ __ ] that
we're not we're not going to have that
information that information is wrong
they're trying to take it away they're
trying to ban them from you keep your
gas stove keep it on matter of fact turn
the burner on and make social media
videos and just turn it on that way you
waste all the gas so so [ __ ] them and
and this because they think it's some
kind of climate control thing it wasn't
about climate control it was about
carbon monoxide poisoning it's really
stupid stuff but again it's the
Republicans who don't care you know
they're like oh man we're gonna own the
lives by getting ourselves killed
they're gonna get covered they're going
to do this we're gonna we're gonna get
carbon monoxide poisoning
I guess at the end of the day if that's
what you need to do to prove yourself to
be the one who won this conversation and
have the last laugh yeah I'm sure as
you're having a coughing fit or you know
trying to laugh the joke off hey hey
well you know one that's not caused by
you intentionally this is them trying to
own the lids right yeah and as they try
to reach for the door or the window to
get some air ventilation to breathe
they're out right well that happens
um it could and and something like that
couldn't happen to a better person than
me again speaking of Matt gants
bone end of the week
and our winner of bonehead of the week
representative George Santos if that is
his name he's the winner now bonetta of
the week Gabe Sanchez and he has a
little well you have a little clip here
for me to play of him and Matt Getz I
think this is significant because this
is a clip of Steve bannon's show right
Steve Bannon is mac and I watched this
interview Steve Bannon Is On Assignment
whatever that means sounds like he has a
criminal a criminal court case that he's
got to get to maybe on assignment I
gotta show up and I Gotta Give testimony
so Matt gatz that scumbag yeah is um Co
or our special guest houses co-host here
is presumably George Santos we don't
know if that's his real name
um or even if this is some sort of uh
alien life form and it's just a skin
suit we're nice to give everyone
just to give everyone context Matt Gates
asks uh George Santos again we don't
know that's his real name and also if
it's not his real name does that mean he
was running on a fake name and then does
that actually mean that he should be in
office there's a whole question there
but of course Kevin McCarthy says what
crime has he been charged with the
crimes they're literally they're
literally building the crime in the case
right now so I'm sure it'll come out
soon enough but here right now one of
those crimes would be the financial
crimes of his campaign and Matt Gates
asked George Santos about where the
money came from and the answer and not
only the answer the responsible by Matt
Gates is
let's let's take a listen one of the
principal critiques I've heard is that a
lot of money uh was donated to your
campaign by you 700 000 I believe where
did it come from well I'll tell you
where it didn't come from it didn't come
from China Ukraine or barisma how about
that well yeah that that is an answer
one of the principles yeah
oh oh buddy that that I didn't expect
that uh boy that's more Republican than
I could come up with why does anyone
think that George Santos is is some sort
of outlier in the Republican party yeah
why even Matt gates in that moment was
like okay I mean that's a i i that's
probably what I that's what I would say
that's what I would well I also don't
know if that's necessarily what he would
say I think Matt Gates was honestly
surprised and was expecting some more
political answer instead of like oh
here's a it's not barisma it's not
Ukraine whatever and so I said instead
Matt Gates like oh I mean yeah yeah
we're threw in all the essentials he
threw in all the essentials he's giving
a non-answer of where it actually came
from because he can't tell the truth
about that so he did that because he
said I'll tell you where it didn't come
from he threw in the word China which oh
God you talk about a good buzzword
you threw that one in Ukraine everyone
knows that this [ __ ] box got the money
from [ __ ] Russia probably and who
who's Russia's enemy right Enemy Number
One right now other than Ukraine so
that's telling and they love Putin and
they hate Ukraine because Ukraine's
trying to fight for their own democracy
and they can't have that when a country
and a Sovereign Nation is trying to
fight for their democracy they don't
want that when people stand up and fight
for democracy so that's perfect
beautiful and then then he says barisma
which is Hunter Biden's laptop Hunter
Biden dick pics this is beautiful George
Santos is one of the best Republicans
this is one of the best Republican
responses I've seen to this question
what do you what is anyone talking about
this guy this guy should be the leader
of the party for crying out loud and I
don't I don't disagree with you I think
that the response that he gave was was
perfect I just wanted to point that out
no no totally I mean it is a what was
that moment for sure wait what was that
you just said what okay but the idea
that Matt Gates
I think he was expecting a different
answer like he was expecting at least
something to be like oh well it came
from donors and I'd like to keep them
private or whatever it is no or or hey
this came from this loan was done
through this group or whatever or just
something right but this is I'll tell
you what it's not and Matt Gates is like
it's probably the best I'm gonna get out
of you so we'll just move on
um anyway you know but I think it's
hilarious because the other day we
played this video and I'm not gonna
Replay that where he gets in the
elevator and he says
142 people if they tell me I will say
what he meant to say was 142
000 right because he said that in this
interview with Matt Getz right right
right yeah and he's like what I meant to
say was 142 000 and he clarifies 132
000. why 100 142 000 are the people that
elected him in New York's third right so
he's saying if all 142 000 people that
voted for me say You must resign then
I'll resign but he said and we'll watch
the video here he says the elevator cut
him off
but oh what no no I'm not I'm not gonna
watch that video oh okay I'm gonna watch
another video where he's okay well just
so just so people have context in the
elevator when he's
doing the 40-yard dash away from
reporters into the elevator with the
former Aid to Madison cawthorne and the
uh and the Opera and the operations
director who worked and works with Steve
Bannon
nothing could go wrong there all
connected go wrong there normally wait
wait is this is this the same Aid that
um helped organize the the cocaine sex
orgies is this the no I don't I don't
know if it's that one I don't know so
there's that there's there's a Madison
Madison right he works for him he's not
in this clip but he's in all the other
elevator clips uh he's also in the Lost
clip where he's like going around the
hallways I don't know where like this
other guy did you think that guy being
there with Madness and Gotham wouldn't
know where he was at probably not
probably I mean who knows maybe he I
mean you would think if he's going to
all those different offices he would
know but in this clip that you're about
to show it's got a guy named uh Vish
bura b-u-r-r-a he works with Bannon
uh with foreign entities he also was a
special operations uh I forget his name
but Special Operations a title for Matt
Gates okay he also worked with other
people in New York that are corrupt wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait because we just
watched the clip of Steve bannon's show
with Matt Getz uh-huh guest hosting and
George Santos sitting next to him that
seems like that seems like this all has
something to do with each other it like
I said it is all connected right the
idea that these people are independent
of each other in in how they they work I
mean if you were to go let's say to the
LinkedIn profile of said uh
I can find it oh I know where it is uh
the to this guy Vish right
the idea is that
you I bet it says pronouns Patriot ass
kick this vishbura President founder and
CEO of ballistic or basilics basilics uh
strategies LLC and Cobra creatives LLC
um multi-talented professional proven
experience and Technology media politics
and government a Master General assist
with generalist with empirical knowledge
in a range of class socioeconomic and
Industrial environments and amalgamation
of Bobby Alex oh my God okay I didn't
even read this part yet an amalgamation
of Bobby Axelrod which people know he is
the CEO and and Trader on billions Ray
Donovan who's a [ __ ] uh fixer Hitman
odd job who is a villain in James Bond
Jay Gatsby the Buddha and Willy Wonka
and this guy's rap sheet of people he's
worked for he has par he's the executive
secretary vice president of New York
young Republican Club he was the
director of communications for Carl
Paladino in New York he a special
operations coordinator for Congressman
Matt gates from the May 2000 uh to May
2021 to May 2022.
this guy and he's a producer on the War
Room oh man he sounds like a [ __ ] box
but this is a clip that you posted
um it says George Santos is tripping
over his own lines well you reposted
from Kevin fry right let's watch this
has one million views let's watch him he
does he literally trip over him let's
watch yeah Congressman Congressman
Santos what what is your response to
those that are calling for you to resign
that's Vish um I will not resign I will
be continuing to hold my office elected
by the people and how do you feel like
you're able to serve your people
there we go
uh he literally back let's play it back
let's see it again what's going on there
he literally trips on
Congressman Congressman Santos what what
is your response to those that are
calling for you to resign
um I will not resign I will be
continuing to hold my office elected by
the people and how do you feel like
you're able to serve your people
he tripped over and what actually if you
really want to know he tripped over a
newspaper and I'm sure there's news in
there about his lies oh yeah the idea
that
can you pull me the clip where he's on
uh he I think it's January 5th 2021
where Jordan
because I believe that clip is not
getting enough
um circulation so I want to play here
while we're talking about this this uh
typical Republican uh George Santos I
want everyone out there to understand
that that's why I say that he is a
typical Republican this is not [ __ ]
new that Republicans lie their asses off
again he's just he just he did it the
wrong way and they all do it right
they're professionals he's an amateur
that's the difference
um he sucks at it and he might be
getting better but this is this is the
same George Santos
um and uh forgive me I think this is
January 5th right yes it is January 5th
2021
um
he's an insurrectionist too Gabe he is
wow so let's watch this clip it's about
a minute long let's watch this
hey Washington
my name's George Santos I'm from New
York City okay right there whoa whoa
whoa that makes me believe that his name
is not George Santos and he's not from
New York City I don't know about you but
when he says stuff like that makes me
think that it's not true but let's go on
if you're from New York you know what
they did to me they did to me what they
did to Donald J Trump they stole my
election for 14 days I was a congressman
elect of the third congressional
district of New York the first ever
biggest upset for a republican in New
York City and what did they do when they
were too busy printing 280
000 ballots in my district and shipping
them to Pennsylvania
so all lies all of it can you imagine
George Santos telling a lie oh boy that
is not true uh everything this guy says
ever is is amazing that's why I don't
believe that he is actually his name is
actually George Santos and he is from
New York City I don't believe any of
that let's finish this up here because
he he's gonna tell some other Whoppers
here oh he's gonna tell some good ones
and listen these are not [ __ ] these
are not outwire lies these are the same
lies that Carrie Lake and all these
other [ __ ] have been saying the
whole time they're not new Republican
outlying lies they're just the same old
[ __ ]
they sneaked in a few for my opponent
and what did they do they stole it
they're gonna convince me and all of you
that Donald Trump lost the senile Biden
who here thinks that Biden cheated
listen to what he says
to overturn the election for Donald J
Trump
and there it is folks he's an
insurrectionist who is he who is ready
to overthrow
and overturned the election so that
Donald J Trump can be the he's an
insurrectionist and he's a bonehead and
he's our bonehead of the week because
you vote you decided as the moment of
the week and this week gave Sanchez they
decided the exact way I thought they
would I was just interested to see if
George Santos really would beat Donald
Trump this week but he did he did it you
did it your vote came in let's give
George Santos if that is his name his
due
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
why didn't you pick a picture out with
his glasses do you think there's a
prescription you think that's fake too I
think they're fake
I think they're fake hey totally doesn't
need they don't they they are not real
they're the glasses that you wear when
everyone else is glasses and you're like
I want glasses to look cool right or you
go like trying to look smart is he
trying to look smart
because it gives the impression that it
makes them more intelligent when really
you just have to be [ __ ] intelligent
well or just believe the opposite of
what they say because they're all lies
again George Santos is not an outlier in
the Republican Party he is a typical
Republican he just likes all the lies
not just a few of them and if you want
to see more of this style content come
here every Friday on the Tony Michaels
podcast bonehead of the week airs every
single Friday in the second hour and a
clip on Midas Dutch Network make sure to
subscribe to our Channel now we're
trying to get to 20 000. get us to 20
000 on our YouTube channel so if you're
watching right now on another YouTube
channel another platform come over to
the Tony Michaels podcast on YouTube and
subscribe we're gonna do a huge drive to
get to 20 000 and hell if you're on the
minus touch Network hit that subscribe
button down there too also to vote for
bone in the week you go to Tony Michaels
pod on Twitter
or you can vote on the YouTube channel
so again that's why you gotta subscribe
and go to the community Tab and you can
vote every week every single week and
you can download every Friday's episode
on Apple Spotify Google and listen to
bonetta the week in the second hour of
Friday's episode
oh boy
a lot of bone-ins this week but um
George Santos boy he beat the he beat
the pants off these other boneheads I
mean
at one point I sent you a screenshot
last night where it was literally twice
it was tied between McCarthy and Santos
on Twitter 43.6 to 43.6 he came out at
the end uh obviously yeah but yeah for a
moment I was like oh this could go
either way you know the man the man
who's the fraud of the man who's
protecting the fraud well you know that
that these are Republicans these are
Republicans it happens that way everyone
thanks for joining us this morning of
the week if you're on the live podcast
right now stick around we have a few
announcements this has been your
addition a bonehead of the week foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
of the week everyone loves that segment
we're at two and a half two and a half
hours today we are over time I apologize
but I don't because great content there
at bonehead of the week's best segment
of the week I love ending the week with
bone and I know the audience does too
speaking of the audience
we're working hard here to get to 20 000
and we need your help we need your help
desperately so if you're on another
platform or you're on YouTube right now
hit the Subscribe button make sure to
share this with through your family
three your friends even your Maga family
invite them get them pissed off who
knows maybe they'll get so mad they
stick around for a little bit of time to
realize their poor charity is crazy I
mean I don't know if you saw this Tony
but McCarthy and the Republicans of the
House of Representatives are now
considering expunging Trump's
impeachment well really well I'm sure
that I'm sure that'll work out just
great for them I'm sure everything they
do won't turn into liquid [ __ ] at all
and their lies and their [ __ ] won't
be exposed I'm sure of it now I I am
sure it will be because that's what we
do here every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central
for two full hours is make sure you
understand the truth real and raw no
[ __ ] and we give it with flair and
style and a little bit of the f word
sprinkled in there every once in a while
yeah just a little bit so come come them
and follow us here on YouTube also give
us a follow over on
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod download
every single episode go follow us on
Facebook as well
have a great weekend you are the best
audience in the world give love to the
best moderators in the world in our chat
everyone have a great weekend Gabe
Sanchez you have a great save weekend
too
until Monday
Surf's Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn hadass Beacon